We're here with Eric Kim,
author of his debut cookbook, "Korean American."
And Eric is bringing back the nostalgic TV dinner
with a modern twist.
I mean, I love this.
I talk about TV dinners all the time.
I feel like we need to modernize them.
What was your like point of view?
You know, I really think that a TV dinner
is about the comforting flavors
that you remember from your childhood.
You know, this one's just a little more homemade,
but the potatoes they get kind of like crispy at the edges.
Oh yeah, they do.
That was really good.
And you do, you have like a little medley.
I love that those are also garnished,
which we didn't have on this one,
but we're gonna garnish right now.
Some sesame seeds.
That's it.
With a little Sesame seed.
Good way to portion control too.
Yeah, it's true.
We have two best friends in the audience, Whitney and Tim.
Where are you?
Hi, guys.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
And we like communal eating here.
So will you guys taste this along with us?
Oh, absolutely.
Yes.
How long have you guys been friends?
Three years.
Oh my God.
I'm so excited.
What'd she eat first?
You like it?
I'm so happy for you.
So happy to be new friends with you, Eric.
This is the most beautiful sauce.
It's so sweet and tangy.
And tangy and sweet and like savory.
Oh my God.
Worcestershire sauce is amazing if you like really use it.
I like overdoing flavors to balance each other out.
I also find potato sauce,
even though this is on the warmer side,
cooling to the palette after something so zesty.
Exactly.
Whitney and Tim, thoughts quickly before we end the show.
Amazing.
So good.
Delicious.
The ribs are so good.
The sauce is just, ugh.
It's incredible.
I'm so glad.
Very happy.
Oh my God, well, thank you so much for eating with us.
And Eric Kim, your beautiful new cookbook,
"Korean American, Food That Tastes Like Home,"
which really is about home.
It's, you know, a love letter to your mother.
And I think this is a show about writing love letters
in book forms to our families.
So thank you so much.
This is sold wherever books are sold.
Get your hot little hands on this beautiful book.
(upbeat bright music)